we come now to what feels like the end
of a long and labyrinth and journey
through all sorts of contexts and
concepts and all sorts of distinctions
and false starts and we ought to go this
way instead of going this way and here's
where Western metaphysics is gone on
heidegger's part in this this work the
origin of the work of art now we're
actually going to get to the origin
we've gotten the essence of the work of
art which is to set forth truth and to
create a or bring forth a world and
earth which exists in strife with each
other we manage to distinguish all sorts
of different improperly applied concepts
of the thing we nature of the work now
we're getting close to the end and we
are actually close to the end of the the
last section that we are looking at the
the art and truth and now we're
switching to talk about yet another new
concept creativeness what is it to
create what is it to be a creator what
is it to be created what is creation
so Heidegger says and I'm going to pick
up where we left off with the last video
we now indeed grasp the essence of truth
more clearly in certain respects what is
not what is that work work in the work
may accordingly have become clear but
the works now visible work being still
does not tell us anything about the
works closest and most obtrusive reality
the Thinley aspect of the work and why
is this the closest and most impressive
reality well remember when we talked
about earth and world the earth is that
which shelters that which which conceals
that which juts forth into the world
which is revealed by the work the world
which in the art work first takes on its
its luminosity its intelligibility it
creates a space of openness and the
material aspects of the work of art
whether they be tones of me
whether they be color in a painting
whether they be the stone the wood the
gold of the temple whether they be the
very language itself that's being used
in a work of poetry or the bodies of the
actors the masks and ancient tragedy all
of those are part of Earth in the
artwork so all of those are part of the
thing Li aspect of the work and he says
indeed it almost seems as though in
pursuing the exclusive aim of grasping
the world's independence as purely as
possible we to overlook the one thing
the work is always a work which means it
is something effected something creative
since the work is created in creation
requires a medium out of which and in
which it creates the thing the element
enters into the work there will always
be this interplay of earth and world not
only because that is demanded for the
advent of truth in the work but because
there always has to be a thing Li
element of which the work is composed
and that is always going to take us to
to earth
take us to ground so to speak so he says
the question remains how does being
created belong to the work it says this
can be elucidated only if two points are
cleared up so he's setting himself an
agenda here first what do being created
and creation mean here and distinction
from making and being made good question
we have a pretty good conception of
different modes of making and being made
is there something different about the
artwork second what is the inmost
essence of the work itself from which
alone can be gauged how far creativeness
belongs to the work and how far it
determines the work being the kind of
being that it is of the work so he says
creation is here always thought in
reference to the work so put aside you
know Jewish Christian Muslim
conceptions of creation particularly
creation next me hello Heidegger has
something something quite different in
mind
he says to the essence of the work
belongs the happening of truth from the
outset we just simply define the essence
of creating by its relation to the
essence of truth as the unconcealed and
of beings the pertinence of creativeness
to the work can be elucidated only by a
more fundamental clarification of what
the essence of truth and that's why I
have this schema here should be familiar
to you from the other videos if you've
if you've seen them and if you want to
know more about this there's also the
video on the essence of truth itself
which goes into greater detail about
this interplay between the concealing
and unn concealing so Heidegger is going
to frame this at the very end of this
section in terms of happening we talked
about this a little bit before now it's
going to finally come into its own
what is truth that it can happen is or
even must happen as art how is it that
there is art at all so it says all right
let's let's begin again art is that the
origin of the artwork and the artists
origin is the Providence of the essence
in which the being of the being
essentially unfolds we've had this
before as origin origin means you know
where the essence is coming from so we
need to look at the essence we need to
do metaphysics what is art we looked at
the essence of art we looked in the
actual work and that led us to truth and
truth led us to the strife between earth
and world and as and like he says repose
happens in the concentrated agitation of
the striving you know for somebody who
rejects Hegel's dialectics Heidegger
system the dialectical thinker as far as
his stylistics go so he says the self
composure the work is grounded here so
in the work the happening of truth is at
work but what is thus at work is so in
the world
this is all within the work so you know
to take a few examples if a if a music
peace a symphony for example is a Haida
garyun work of art this strife between
world and earth the the play between
openness and unconcealed meant
concealing the double concealment that
occurs the concealment of concealment
the concealing within beings and beings
even in the open space all of that is
happening within the the work of art
which is which is you know in the sense
of a piece of music being played again
something which has many creators all of
whom are working hopefully and more or
less tandem with each other so he says
the actual work is here already
presupposed as the bearer of the
happening of this at once the problem of
the thinly feature of the work again
confronts us what is it what is this
stuff that the works are made of one
thing finally becomes clear he says
however zealously we inquire into the
work self-sufficiency will fail to find
its actuality as long as we don't agree
to take the work as something worked as
effective as produced by somebody so how
are you understand this process of
creation he says let's think about
creation as bringing forth now does that
solve the problem for us
no because other things count as
bringing forth as well the creation of
equipment for example so Bach camera for
a moment this is equipment this is not a
work of art this is an iPhone this is
technology this does not produce the
strife between world and earth and open
up to us an entire region of truth it
could mediate that sort of thing it
could be a tool for us to do that sort
of thing but it doesn't by itself
represent anything like that
but he made that somebody created that
and there was a lot of creation involved
in this
there was the design there was you know
the creation of all the component parts
the apps putting it together imagining
this entire way of life that goes along
with with the iPhone yet all of that is
merely equipment for Heidegger's so
creation is bringing forth making them
equipment is bringing forth handicraft
you know you can't find a iPhone and you
couldn't have an iPhone that was made up
in a wood and stone and made by some
artisanal practisin er who had you know
learned his craft at the hands of you
know some master walk in some rural area
that's not the kind of thing it is but
we do have other things that that aspire
to that handicraft is not the same thing
as works of art there's different types
of making different types of creating
going on here
he says it's as difficult to track down
the essential features of the creation
of works in the making of equipment as
it is to distinguish verbally between
the two modes of bringing forth we find
the same procedure in the activity of
Potter and sculptor of joiner and
painter the creation of a work requires
craftsmanship great artists prized
craftsmanship most highly they are the
first to call for it's painstaking
cultivation based on complete mastery
they above all others constantly take
pains to educate themselves ever anew in
thorough craftsmanship and so the Greeks
had a word that they used very
indiscriminately for the the skill or
the the whatever it is that the creator
or the maker or the shaper had and they
called it
the word from which we get technology
which by the way or interestingly first
use of the word technology or its
cognate occurs in Aristotle and there he
is actually talking about people who
write textbooks people who read
textbooks on rhetoric in particular so
he says it seems advisable to define the
essence of creative work in terms of its
craft aspect but in reference to the
linguistic the reference of the
linguistic usage of the Greek must give
us some Clause we have to be careful
oftentimes we think if we just you know
trace the words back and like put some
Greek or Latin words up on the board
only Greek of course Herr Heidegger
who's Latin this you know he's
derivative for him
we solved the matter hangers saying back
up there hold on a second is this really
what we want to focus on is techne going
to be the answer to our riddle here so
easy says Technic knifies neither craft
nor art that would be kind of an
interesting thing to say to people who
studied Greek doing it because that's
oftentimes how we translate it not at
all the technical in our present-day
sense either it's not technique it's not
technology it never means a kind of
practical performance so what does it
mean he says it denotes a type of or a
mode of knowing and that is exactly how
Aristotle actually uses the term
technique and Plato in you know is sort
of referring to it in similar senses
Aristotle is using the word techne like
that in Nicomachean ethics book six
where he's he's actually looking at
techne most exclusively and when he
talks about the the art of rhetoric the
technical you know hey techne rhetoric a
that seems to be what he has in mind a
mode of knowing to know means to have
seen which means to apprehend what is
present for Greek thought the essence of
knowing consistent Allah day of
Revelation openness of beings it
supports and guides comportment towards
beings
is a bringing forth of beings and that
it brings forth what is present and is
as such out of concealment and into the
unconsumed of its appearance technique
by itself never signifies the action of
making what does well that was actually
poiesis making Tecna is that by which
one does that so I says the artist is
not is is a technic AIT's not because
he's a craftsman because both the
setting forth of works and the setting
forth of equipment occur in a bringing
forth that causes in the causes beings
in the first place to come forward and
to be present in assuming an upward
aspect so what is it that the technique
ace the the the artists the craftsmen
they actually does he brings beings out
of hiddenness out of concealment
he turns stone or or tin or bronze into
an axe a piece of equipment maybe he
actually embellishes it as well he shows
us what things actually are by making
the things come out of you might say
non-being or at least not being that
kind of being into what they they really
are now you know does everything that
the greeks call the tech may fit in
there
you know sometimes Plato would talk
about the the doctor producing health as
a kind of Technic it's interesting to
think about those sort of questions so
he says this all happens in the midst of
the being that surges upward and growing
of its own accord produces calling art
technique does not all and not at all
imply that the artists action is seen in
the line of craft what looks like craft
and the creation of work is a different
sort
such doing is determined and pervaded by
the essence of creation so he says what
then if not craft if we're not going to
use craft technique to understand the
essence of creation
what do we have to think about in terms
of what constitutes creation and being
creative so he says even though the
works creativeness has a relation to
creation nevertheless both creativeness
and creation must be defined in terms of
the work being of the work what it is to
be a work and so he says we're able to
characterize creationist following to
create what the creator is doing is to
let something emerge as a thing that has
been brought forth the works becoming a
work is a way in which truth becomes and
happens truth shows up comes to light
opens a world up for us in the work of
art so he says what is truth that it has
to happen in such a way of something
creative how does truth hasn't have an
impulse towards of work grounded in its
very essence and he reminds us of
something here he says truth is untruth
insofar as there belongs to it the
reservoir of the not yet revealed for
Heidegger truth in its essence also
contains untruth in part because truth
is always going to be particularized
it's always going to be situated yeah
there's always going to be more that
could be understood there's always going
to be you might say a penumbra or you
know mysterious portions were enigmatic
ambiguous parts that we may not even
realize it as ambiguous until we start
probing into them so he says a nun
concealment as truth there occurs the
other on of a double restraint or
refusal truth essentially occurs as such
in the opposition of clearing and double
concealing so truth to go back to this
this concept is going to have to involve
at least in the work of art the
opposition between world and earth but
even in the normal conception not the
normal conception of truth is
propositional or actuality but the
deeper normal conception of true
as unveiling for Heidegger when we
realize the truth of something for
instance I realize that I am in fact in
love with this woman over here there is
an openness there is a unconcealed
things become apparent but yet in that
very unconcealed there are other things
that are being concealed there are other
things that remain hidden that's what
he's what he's talking about here so he
says whenever this strife between
concealed nests and unconcealed this or
clearing and concealing breaks out and
happens the opponents move apart because
of it and that opens up a place of
strife this openness of the open region
that is truth can be what it is only if
and as long as it establishes itself
within its open region so there must
always be some being and when we get to
larger not just conglomerations or
Assemblies of being but an entire
horizon we have a world so he says that
this is what what you know we mean by
thesis by a place setting up so truth
happens he says only by establishing
establishing itself in the strife and
the free space opened up by truth itself
there is a sort of self referentiality
to truth in the deeper sense that
Heidegger means truth consistent in
unconcealed right so something is
unconcealed that produces an open region
within that open region there can be the
strife between one concealment itself
and the concealing that is still taking
place all around it and within it that
is truth for Heidegger that's something
that's very difficult I think to wrap
your head around it take some some
thinking in order to do but it is
possible and it does actually make sense
so I would suggest at this point if
you're puzzled about what that is rewind
the video just
look to go back over that that portion
so he says because truth is the
opposition of clearing and concealing
there belongs to it what is here to be
called establishing and this is going to
be another key idea for him but truth
does not an existed it beforehand
somewhere among the Stars truth has to
happen truth has to come into being
itself so it says clearing of openness
and establishment in the open region
belong together they're the same single
essence of the happening of truth he
says this happening is historical in
multiple ways now here he is going to
tell us about a number of different ways
in which truth can they actually come
into being as historical this is a very
important movement right here we not
only want to ask ourselves what are the
different modes of historical being by
which truth he answers this impulse
within its very essence to intrude
itself through the working of a worker a
creator a founder through foundation to
bring truth into being to carry out the
clearing that he's talking about
Heidegger is not going to confine
himself here to discussing works of art
he's going to think about other
analogous foundings another thing to
keep in mind as we go through this list
is this is not necessarily an exhaustive
list of the possibilities or even the
historical actualities of the advent the
coming to be of truth in in the clearing
so he says one essential way in which
truth establish itself in the beings it
has opened up is truth setting itself
into work the work of art another way
in which truth occurs is the act that
founds a political state it's a very
interesting thing for Heidegger to say
the act that founds a political state
and this is fraught with all sorts of
problems and possibilities because which
act do you actually decide constitutes
the one which establishes a historical
state that's always a problematic
question you know for the American state
was it the Constitution is it the same
Articles of Confederation before
is it the Declaration of Independence is
it is it something else perhaps you know
Thomas Paine's Common Sense or you know
something like that it's difficult to
say precisely when that happens but you
notice that every state has its origin
stories it has its narrative of how this
founding took place it says still
another way in which truth comes to
shine forth is in the nearness is the
nearness of that which is not simply a
being but the being which is most in
being the being which is most in being
when somebody has an encounter with
being and they may not use the word
being for this they may use the word the
divinity the gods strife fate
Primal truth
than the nature of reality itself but
those are cases where if somebody is
able to communicate that they're able to
give us a glimpse into what it is that
truth took on what shaped truth to kind
historically for them still another way
in which truth grounds itself is the
essential sacrifice that's a really
interesting thing to say what happens in
a sacrifice this is not spelled out here
when you have a sacrifice one thing is
put in place of another and it's only
truly a sacrifice if what is sacrificed
is at the same time recognized as not
being as good or as valuable as that
which is sacrificed for but at the same
time as being of values being good as
being a loss in the process still
another way in which truth becomes is
the thinker's questioning which is the
thinking of being names being in it's
question worth is of course this is
Heidegger in being in time posing the
question of being for the very first
time in its full originality but could
this be other philosophers as well they
think so by contrast he says science
science is not original science is not
an original happening of truth but
always the cultivation of a domain of
truth already opened specifically by
apprehending and confirming that which
shows itself to be possibly and
necessarily correct in that field very
interesting conception of science
science is something derivative science
is something less primordial it is a
distinctively human attitude
distinctively human activity within the
world but what it does is it messes
around with beings that it's already
come to know it doesn't actually do
something foundational so that's a very
interesting thing to think happen
so he says wedyn in so far as science
passes beyond correctness and goes on to
a truth which means that it arrives at
the essential
schoolers are beings of such quits being
science what does it become
philosophy so you know you necessarily
don't necessarily have to think of this
in terms of the Natural Sciences which
led to all sorts of Technology think of
the social sciences when the
psychologist quits - quits working with
the within the framework of the
categories that he's already established
and taken for granted and he's been you
know able to to measure or to qualify
and quantify in different ways and
derive a theory and begins to ask
foundational questions like what the
hell am i doing is it is this all just
BS or is this really attached to some
sort of reality that's that's actually
they're independent of my projection of
all these these great categories and
this these techniques unto them that
scientists at that point begins doing
philosophy when the sociologist becomes
concerned that sociology may have lost
its grounding in its historical
development which is a sociologist
actually that really ought to be worried
about I think that's a whole side note
they become philosophers at least
philosophers in the making so he says
because it isn't in the essence of truth
to establish itself within beings in
order thus to become truth the impulse
towards the work lies in the essence of
truth is one of truths distinctive
possibilities so there's an agency here
to truth itself pushing itself into
being pushing itself onto the scene but
it only does so in Heidegger doesn't
spell this out quite as much as I'd like
to see him do this through the agency or
the co agency
beings pedasi so he talks now about
truth establishing itself in the work
and he talks more about you know the the
strife between world and earth and I
want to skip through this fairly quickly
just hitting on the key points that
aren't just repetition of what he said
before so he says as the world opens
itself it submits to the decision of a
historical humanity the world submits to
the decision of historical humanity the
question of victory and defeat blessing
and curse mastery and slavery I talked
about this in the previous video world
is already effectively connected with
all sorts of moral values which can be
contestant which are up for grabs to a
certain extent which do require us to
make decisions to go this way or go that
way the world is not something which is
totally given and imposed upon us we
help to create the world as the world
and if we can test with somebody else
what kind of world is going to be we do
that within the world itself so says the
dawning world brings out what is yet
undecided in measureless and thus
discloses the hidden necessity of
measure and decisiveness somebody gasps
to determine these things says as the
world opens itself the earth comes to
tower it stands forth as that much bear
is all and it creates a rift they have
this jagged thing here the rift think of
it as a sort of borderland between world
and earth where world is opening
everything up earth is pushing itself
back up through that there is a rift at
the border between the two of them
and it's not a stable place for all time
nor is it completely undecided up for
grabs it takes determinate shapes so he
says this riff does not let the
opponent's bring a break apart it brings
what opposes measure and boundary into
its common outline so truth establishes
itself as strife within a being that has
this rift the rift he says is the
drawing together into a unity of sketch
and basic design breach and outline
that's where truth among other things
establishes itself in this rift he says
this occupying can happen only if what
is to be brought forth the rift and
Trust itself to the self secluding
element that juts into the open region
the rift must must set itself back into
the gravity of stone the mute hardness
of wood the dark little colors as the
earth takes the rift back into itself
the rift is first set forth into the
open region and thus placed within that
much towers of the open region as self
secluding and sheltering he calls this
figure Gestalt he so he says the
creativeness of the work means truth
being fixed in the place of the figure
figure is the structure and who is
shaped the rift composes itself this is
the few he says of the rift shining
where multiple voices are all singing
together so he says in the creation of a
war the strife must be set back into the
earth it can't be something purely
conceptual it can't be something just
potential it has to actually take place
within the elements the thinly elements
out of which the work itself is composed
brilliant thought there which really
tells us a lot about our partner
so he says this does not use up or
misuse the earth as a matter but sets it
free to be nothing but itself this is
how it's different than handicraft this
is how it's different from equipment the
work we've said this in the previous
video the work of art let's the material
aspects be what they are in a way that's
very different than what is what it is
in equipment you know the plastic but
this is composed of I don't notice this
unless it gets in my way I could take
this as an aesthetic object I don't
really I take this as just a tool
plastic can be something in which truth
happens in which beauty occurs but that
would be within the work and that would
have this structure here so he says
let's now talk about the Creator the
emergence of creativeness from the work
does not mean that the work is to give
the impression of having been made by a
great artist he says the point is not
that the creative being be certified as
the performance of a capable person so
that the producer is thereby brought to
public notice it is not the so it's
Beckett this also did this that is to be
made known rather the simple fact of
essence to be held forth into the open
region by the work you know think for
example of Homer's Odyssey and Iliad
brilliant brilliant works in part the
product of something that Homer took
from other bards reworked stamped his
own genius upon it's not as if Homer was
a big guy before that that everybody
should have looked to it said oh my god
Homer made this Wow now we got to read
this book
no it's the work itself which said
look at this world look at the things of
this look at the strife between them now
who made this holy crap who is that guy
who was he what mind and then Homer of
course points he muses help me tell this
story he's not doing it entirely honest
upon his own very different than the
attitude that we tend to him about
authors musicians artists these days
where we wait I know this is gonna be
great because this person's you know
produce great stuff beforehand and you
know it comes out we're like ah yeah I'm
more of the same not so good and we're
disappointed that's because we have the
wrong attitude towards art we're looking
for art genuine art where it's not going
to appear the Creator is the creator
because the Creator is creator of art so
he says the more essentially the work
opens itself the more luminous becomes
the uniqueness of the fact that it is
rather than it is not it thrusts itself
before us it poses itself to us as that
which must be taken account of and that
which cannot be entirely understood even
though it's brought into a region of
openness where we see things that we we
didn't even conceive of as possibilities
for us and for our understanding so he
says and now I'm going to switch gears a
little bit the more solitary the work
fixed in the figure stands on its own
the more cleanly it seems to cut ties to
all human beings including its creator
the more simply does the thrust come
into the open that such a work is it
shows us its being and the more
essentially is the extraordinary thrust
of the surface and what is long familiar
thrust down he says this is not violent
however the more purely the work is
itself transported it to the open
beings the more simply does it transport
us into this openness and at the same
time transport out of the realm of the
ordinary now what does that mean this is
the sort of aspect of what is often
called an aesthetics defamiliarization
the artwork brings to us and opens up
within being because this is a
possibility for being an entire realm of
bonus of unconcealed this
thing's persons places that we hadn't
conceived of before experiences that is
world world also exists like we said
many times in relation to earth they
have this this relationship of strife to
each other which is you know figured in
the rift now in our ordinary lives we
exist in a world we also exist in earth
Heidegger is saying that what the
artwork does and what the artist does is
transport us from our ordinary world or
ordinary environment to a different
world one which could he doesn't bring
this out quite enough enrich the world
in which we live so he says to submit to
this displacement means that transform
are accustom ties to world on earth and
henceforth to restrain all usual doing
and prising knowing and looking in order
to stay within the truth that is
happening in the work that's a very good
point to make real appreciation of art
requires that we actually put some of
the things of the world to rest so that
you know for example if we're looking at
an artwork and we're doing it on our
computer and we're actually trying to
scrutinize it for example
Rembrandt's philosopher in his in his
study right if we're looking at the play
of the light and Rembrandt perfectly
illustrates this this you know play
between world and earth
should we have a whole bunch of other
windows open at the same time on our
screen probably not
should music be something that we just
have his background so he can pop around
to it oh so nice that will be works of
art done to really appreciate music we
have to create the space within
ourselves within our environment to
actually pay attention to what's going
on there to be transported as how to
versus so he says now just as a work
this is another important point just as
a work cannot be without being creative
isn't essentially in need of create or
as it calls to them make me bring me
into being what is creative cannot
itself come into being without those who
preserve it the audience you might say
but not only the audience the
appreciators and I would actually go so
far as to say with certain types of art
those who continue to enact it the
musicians playing a symphony are not
creating something completely new in a
sense they're preservers in Heidegger's
sense that he's using this here but
there is this relationship between
preservers and creators they're both
needed for the work of art to be the
work of art you know refer to sustain a
world and its relationship to earth so
he says if a work does not find
preservers does not immediately find
them capable of responding the truth
happening and the work this does not at
all mean that the work may also be at
work without preservers being a work it
is always essentially tied to preservers
even and particularly when it is only
waiting for them or perhaps waiting for
them again
think about for example John Duns
metaphysical poetry
some of the most profound poems written
fell out of style you know as well after
a while they were seen as being gloomy
who wants to read that crap and the
attitude that a lot of other people had
because they couldn't enter into that
den world and the earth of what was was
being consumed perhaps they they lost
the theological vision that he was
interested in and then came the 20th
century and the rediscovery of these
metaphysical poets including one of the
greatest among them John Donne and
suddenly these works of art which are
not really about John Donne they are the
works that matter
they now have preservers again putting
this off I'm a great fan of that
particular poetry so it says even the
Oblivion in which the work can sink is
not nothing and is still a preservation
it feeds on the work preserving the work
means standing within the openness of
beings that happens in the world having
some sort of connection being able to
see what it is that the world being able
to see through the vistas that the work
opens up he might say he calls this a
knowing and he says knowing does not
consist in mere information and notions
about something this is not the kind of
knowledge like what we find in Wikipedia
for example or by googling
rather if you wanted to connect it to
something on the internet you would be
watch a YouTube video with somebody who
actually knows what they're doing and is
trying their best to explain what
they're doing to an audience that doing
is also knowing and Heidegger connects
here in the the preservers knowing and
will it shoes is how we normally
conceive of is willing but there are
choices that are made in sort of a
luminosity before as they have this
option of this option we get you know
the menu should I have the hamburgers
they have the roast beef sandwich should
I have a fish sandwich should I go with
another restaurant and maybe have tacos
should I perhaps not you know eat any of
this stuff at all and fast for this meal
those are options there's a deeper level
to willing and Heidegger is not the only
person to point this out there are other
people as well st. Anselm is a good
example Dietrich von Hildebrand another
great thing you know a phenomenologist
points this out there's many people who
point this this out there the Willing
like he says the Willing here referred
to which neither merely applies
knowledge i know what the options are
i'm gonna make it happen nor decides
beforehand is thought in terms of the
basic experience of thinking knowing
that remains a willing willing that
remains a knowing is the existing human
beings ecstatic stepping outside of
themselves entry into the unconcealed of
being capital B it is one of the most
foundational experiences but it's not
just an experience that gives us sort of
passivity to it it is also activity but
it is an experiment that one of the most
foundational deep experiences that we
can handle calls us the resoluteness
says it's not the deliberate action of a
subject but the opening up of human
being out of its captivity of in beings
to the open
of you that is what the preservers are
doing with the artwork that's part of
what it means to be a preserver to be a
preserver for Heidegger is something
very different than say being a
connoisseur or being a dilettante or
being a patron all those would be more
superficial relations than to be a
preserver the preserver may not actually
be able to articulate just what it is
that they find fascinating in this work
and what it is that that they get out of
it in in Coweta
terms in articulate terms that the
critic might understand but the critic
might actually not understand which is
too bad cuz could you case means judge
Wright might not understand the work of
art that they know so many things about
but don't actually know why not because
they don't will and know rightly at the
same time on this foundational level
they will they will terr in an article
about it they will to go to this
exhibition they will to go over here and
talk about this over here but that's on
a surface level compared to what
Heidegger is calling resoluteness so he
says willing is the sober undone
closedness of that extensional
transcendence which exposes itself to
the openness of beings that has sent
into the work preserving the work is
knowing as a sober standing within the
awesomeness of the work of the truth
that is happening within the work the
knowledge which is a willing makes its
home in the works truth unless only
remains of knowing does not deprive the
work of its independence this is not
dragging - a sphere of mere lived
experience does not degraded into the
role of a stimulator of such experience
artwork is not there to turn us on to
Jasna some to make us feel certain
things because it's not about us the
artwork is about the world the earth
what's going on with it if this dynamism
and we're able to go along for the ride
Heidegger would say if we will if we
know if we direct ourselves rightly
preserving the work like he says does
not reduce people to their private
experiences but brings them into
affiliation with the truth happening in
the world that means that preservers
should be able to recognize something
within the other preservers again they
may not be able to put this into
explicit language but this is something
really key isn't it when you run across
those with whom you have a fundamental
love for a particular genre of music
which has moved you which has open
things up for you you are sharing
something that goes far beyond you and
that person your own personal being your
own little experiences your sharing in
something like walking through a
Cathedral together aren't you so I says
the proper way to preserve the work is
co-created and prescribed only and
exclusively by the work each work if we
listen to it attentively
tells us what we ought to do to preserve
it you know another thing that's he
doesn't talk about this here is but this
is worth thinking about it as a
digression you as a human being cannot
be a preserver of every artwork and it's
not your job to do that oftentimes when
we become aware through this this primal
experience of the awesomeness of certain
art and that can include philosophical
works by the way for me that would
include things like humans treaties and
Thomas Aquinas is so matteo [ __ ] and st.
Anselm's prosto Joe and Plato's
symposium and Descartes meditations when
we become aware of the awesomeness in
them we oftentimes feel ourselves under
this this obligation of oh my gosh this
entire world is opened up to me and I
see so many other people not
appreciating it I should appreciate as
much as I possibly can i should give as
much of myself as a preserver to the
works well it may be that only one work
is actually great to speak to you that
way and that's okay for hiding her you
could actually be like the guy that I'm
reading I'm reading the moonstone still
I forget the guys name but Robinson
Crusoe is the only book that he actually
gets anything out of Robinson Crusoe is
a pretty good book it becomes for this
guy sort of his Bible he meditates upon
it like a monk meditates in Alexio
Divina
it could be that for example in my case
I am called to be a preserver of the
Odyssey and the Iliad and of the
symposium but not of some other work of
antiquity that's alright it's enough to
find the works that you have this
calling this destiny this possibility of
responsiveness of resoluteness towards
to be a preserver so that's that's a
little soapbox digression back to
Heidegger now so he says as soon as the
thrust into the awesome is parried and
captured by the sphere of familiarity
and Connor kind of soars ship the art
business has begun we've we've lapsed
back into everydayness into something
superficial we don't want to be thinking
just of the artists qualities or its
history or something like that in the
sense of a bunch of data or information
we want to allow ourselves to experience
the rift at the juncture the joint of
world and and earth at this point
Heidegger now tells us that we can
return to what he calls the opening
question of this this essay how do
matters stand with the works thing we
feature that is to guarantee its
immediate actuality what does he mean by
this well we want to understand the
thing the element in the the work of art
not not just for its own sake but so
that we can understand what it is for
the work to be of work and the thing the
element is not the work or the work ly
nature of the work as such but it gives
us clues into it and as he says he tells
us each of these these predominant ways
of understanding what it is to be a
thing are inadequate to understand the
thing ly characteristic or the thing we
dimension
or the thing they feature of the work of
art the materiality of it what he calls
world instead it's it's earthy character
that that has to give us the proper
perspective he says we must aim at the
thing belonging to the earth the essence
of the earth and it's free and unhurried
bearing and self seclusion reveals
itself only in the earth jutting into a
world and we saw that this takes place
in the work of art I'm not going to
rehearse that anymore now where is he
going with this now he's going to start
bringing all the elements back together
he says the actuality of the work has
become not only clear for us in the
light of its work being but also
essentially richer as we've gone through
this this essay as we've thought about
the nature of artistic production
artistic work about even the audience
the appreciators all these these things
we've attained a much richer denser
realer picture of what's going on so he
says the preservers of the work belong
to its creativeness this is a very
interesting thing to say the preservers
of the work the long - it's creating us
with an essencial ax t equal to that of
the creators oftentimes when we think of
art we especially these days we tend to
focus on the artist and we don't focus
on those who with what he calls
resoluteness this willing and thinking
at the same time are the ones who keep
the work of art in its being as a work
of art so he says if art is at the
origin of the work that means that art
lets those who essentially belong
together at work the creator and
preserver originate each in his own
essence so art as such gives us the
artwork it gives us the Creator it gives
us the preserver not as if it creates
them out of you know
nothing itself but it's what lets them
be what they are and in turn they
contribute each with each part of this
each part of this dynamic contributes to
the work of art the on doing experience
the ongoing reality of art so he says
art is a becoming and happening of truth
truth as the clearing and concealing of
beings happens and being composed all
art as the letting happen to the advent
of truth of beings isn't such in essence
poetry now what does he mean by this he
says we don't mean Poe Izzi verse
because we don't want to say that
everything is somehow words just like
put into stone or put into music or
something along those lines
he says that the essence of poetry which
has now been ascertained very broadly is
something that is worthy of questioning
something that still has to be thought
through what do we mean by poetry so he
says if all art is in essence poetry
then the arts of architecture painting
sculpture music must be traced back to
dance but that would be pure
arbitrariness so that can't be what he
means by that
who is he is only one mode of the
clearing projection of truth poetic
composition in the wider sense there is
music there is architecture there is
working in wood there is figure painting
right but he says the linguistic work
poetry in the narrower sense is a
privileged position in the domain of the
Arts why language is its medium language
is not only and not primarily an audible
of written expression of what is to be
communicated all too often we reduce
language in some philosophies of
languages they reduce language to mere
communication they don't see what
language it's deeper essence contains he
says language alone brings beings as
being
into the open for the first time it is
the act of naming of denomination that
allows beings to stand forth as this
kind of being this to be a hand this to
be a jacket this to be a book so he
calls us projecting such saying as a
projecting of clearing which
announcement is made of what it is that
beings come into the open as what kind
of beings are they projective saying is
poetry the saying of world and earth the
saying of the arena of their strife and
thus of the place of all nearness and
remoteness of the guts poetry is the
saying of the unconsumed of beings so in
poetic language which doesn't just mean
you know poems as we tend to think of
them but in language in its poetic
dimension beings are named they are
given articulation if we want to think
about this in the categories of being in
time so he says language preserves the
original essence of poetry building and
plastic creation on the other hand I
always happen already it happened only
in the open region of saying and naming
it is the open region that pervades and
guides them so in a certain sense poetry
is more primordial more foundational so
there are a few other things he needs to
talk about as he moves us through this
he says the essence of art is poetry the
essence of poetry in turn is the
founding of truth the establishment of
truth and he says we understand founding
here in a triple sense founding is
bestowing giving founding is grounding
and founding as beginning so he says
founding though is only actual in
preserving so again we see that the
preservers are just as essential to this
process as the originators as the work
itself so he says to each mode of
founding that corresponds a mode of
preserving and he wants to do this in a
very you know outline form and he says
the truth that does
closes itself in the work can never be
proved or derived from what went before
so that's part of what is integral to
the actual genuine artwork it's not
something derivative it's not something
merely imitative it's not just following
a pattern something new comes into being
so he says what art fountains could
never be compensated and made up for by
what is already at hand and available so
founding is an overflow and that's what
the stole means it's a gift when we
experience an artwork we're being given
something that is gratuitous now does
that mean that it's it's just arbitrary
just coming out of nowhere
could be anything Trustin paint up on
the on the board and now you've got
artwork no because it has to be grounded
he says in the work truth is thrown
towards the coming preservers that is
towards a historical group of human
beings what is cast forth though is
never an arbitrary demand it's never
pure whimsy Cala T you might say truly
poetic projection is the opening up of
that into a human beings as historical
as already cast you're anticipating an
audience you're anticipating those who
will derive meaning from this so he
calls this grounding grounding his
bearing ground and then he talks about
all creation being drawing as of water
from a spring and he says the founding
of truth is our founding now this sense
of free not only a sense of freebus
stole but at the same time foundation in
the sense of this ground laying
grounding poetic projection comes from
nothing in this respect that it never
takes its gift from the ordinary and
traditional yeah it never comes from
nothing in that what it is projected by
it is only the withheld determination of
historical design itself
so this leads us to the conception of
beginning and a beginning is never just
a leap out of nowhere like Heidegger
says beginnings take time to prepare a
genuine beginning of the leap is always
a head start in which everything that
comes already leaped over even as as
something still veiled so the beginning
on the contrary says always contains the
undisclosed abundance of the awesome
which means that it contains strife
itself poetry art work contains strife
with the familiar and the ordinary so he
says always when beings as a whole as
beings themselves to me in a grounding
and openness art attains to the its
historical essences foundation now when
is this happened
Heidegger now is going to really bring
things to close by by talking about what
we call local metaphysics the
metaphysics of an epoch and then another
epoch so he says this foundation
happened in the West for the first time
in Greece what was in the future to be
called being was set into work setting
the standards the realm of beings this
opened up was then transformed into a
being in the sense of God's creation the
shift from antiquity to the Middle Ages
this happened in the Middle Ages this
kind of being was again transformed at
the beginning and during the course of
the modern age beings became objects
that could be controlled and penetrated
by calculation and each time he says a
new and essential world erupted a new
and essential world erupted every epoch
of metaphysics has brought with it
something new some new understanding
some new engagement with beings where
it's gone wrong has it been taking that
as if it covered all being together so
he said each of these was an unconcealed
meant of beings now whenever it happens
he says whenever there's a beginning a
thrust enters history history either
begins or starts over again and not a
sequence of events and Titus's history
is the transporting of a people into its
appointed task as entry into that
people's endowment so history has to do
with human beings with values with a
destiny with a point to it with projects
with something transcending us but
including us and involving us
so he says art is historical and as
historical it is the creative preserving
of truth in the work so he brings us to
a close by saying we inquire into the
essence of art why do we inquire in this
way we inquire this way in order to be
asked be able to ask more properly
whether art is or is not an origin in
our historical existence and whether and
under what conditions a Canon must be in
origin so he says we can't force this
question we can't force art but this
reflective knowledge is preliminary for
the becoming of art only such knowledge
prepares its space for aren't the way
for their creators they look up their
location for its preservers
so Heidegger is saying this conception
of art as historical as the locus of
truth as involving grounding founding
all these these things we've talked
about world strife with with earth
jutting forth all these things help us
to understand the relationship between
creator and preservers through the
artwork and through the essence of art
so he says are we in our existence
historically at the origin are we at a
new origin are we at the cusp of
something different than the ancient
than the medieval than the modern do we
know which means do we give heed to the
essence of the origin or in our relation
to art do we merely make appeal to a
cultivated acquaintance with the past
and it closes with a verse by hurlan
saying which reads sheriff released last
May and immersed or spring vona to date
or or reluctantly that which dwells near
its origin abandons the site now he has
an epilogue here and then he has an
addendum I'm gonna skip the addendum
which I don't think is very interesting
at all and I'm only gonna point out one
thing from the epilogue he's concerned
as he brings this to to the final clause
in the Apple
with whether we're at a time where we
can finally begin to you might say RIA
proprietary and not do so in terms of
the categories of the past that we've
relied on or things like lived
experience subjective experience those
those exhaust themselves those only
carry us so far those don't get us to
the essence of what is going on with
this those don't allow us to be
preservers those don't allow us if we if
we were gifted with the opportunity to
be creators they detach us from the
depths of truth and being and they
thereby even detach us from the
experience of the beautiful in its full
sense so he's concerned and he brings up
Hegel's you know point that art is sort
of played itself out he asks is art
still an essential and necessary way in
which that truth happens which is
decisive for our historical existence
words are no longer this character
that's where all all I'll end this
that's a worthy question that still has
to be thought out over and over again
and I think it can only be thought out
by placing ourselves productively in
contact with genuine art in the sense
that Heidegger is talking about here I
don't think that he understood
everything adequately about art I think
that there's some some dimensions of it
that he passed over that he emphasized a
little bit too much but it's a profound
vision and a very powerful way of
understanding what is going on in the
artwork in the artist and in ourselves
as we come to terms with the meaning of
art for ourselves